hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 10
video just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet it was basically
like would you kill baby Hitler if you
had the chance the funny thing about the
episode is dark as rip hunter got like
he's pointing the gun at the kid my son
died my son never got to learn how to
swim they could have totally killed that
kid and it wouldn't have changed a thing
that's what gideon was saying when they
removed him from the timeline it didn't
change anything when they brought him
back it still didn't change anything so
you can start to see the pattern emerge
and this also kind of synced up with the
flashbacks where I met Hawkgirl or
Hawkman son no matter what you do to try
to avoid some future event it will still
end up happening remember flash season 1
that was the same thing that you Barth
on told to Barry when he time-travel the
first time no matter what you do to try
and change time time will always find a
way to replace the thing that you
changed was something that's even worse
so let's do top five WTF there were a
couple things they changed from the
comics like Sidney Palmer Ray Palmer in
the comics does not have a brother named
Sidney so that was in addition but
number five the name is elector dr.
Hannibal Lecter the most beautiful thing
about this joke is Jax's reaction just
the way he tilts his head like seriously
dude you're going with that and I guess
jewel states character in the future has
never heard of Silence of the Lambs but
number four WTF the reveal that Ray
Palmer's brother took his designs and
co-opted them for military use are
really just for corporate gain but
they're really used more as weapons but
maybe in the past before our
corporations took over he had some sort
of military contract and he used his
atom designs for it if you remember the
atom suit was actually designed based on
military research that Queen industries
was doing it's kind of like a season 3
deep cut now the Omak project I was a
little disappointed it was cool that
they turned the Omak project into the
atom soup but I was hoping to see the
brother eyes satellite from the comics
that would have been so badass but its
side note think about it this way
Sidney now is the character they can
bring on as an antagonist in a future
season give the atom his own villains
there are a lot of atom villains that
they use for the show just in general
Chronos is a good example of that he's a
character that shows up in the atom
comics but they've changed him for the
TV show turned him into more of a
hunter-killer badass number 3 WTF
Captain Cold versus heatwave you can say
trial by fire cleanse by fire either way
he's back to normal
and now they're being hunted down by the
hunters the way he explained them is
that they're like full-blown finger
puppets of the time masters there's
almost no humanity left in them whatever
they used to be
and while Chronos was sent to bring rip
hunter back the hunters mission is only
to kill them on sight so just got
real and they have to go to a different
time to try and stop Vandal Savage
really what it's all working up to is
Hawkgirl has to be the one to kill him
she's the only one that can kill him and
make it stick but she's just not there
yet so number two WTF flashback Hawkgirl
and Hawkman go on the run with their
young son now this is the son that we
saw in an earlier episode as an older
adult who's like hello mother hello
father
you may have forgotten me but I'm your
son it adds a nice character development
but in the context of the episode it's
all about not running anymore
turning around and fighting so you see
how the metaphor works in present-day
as they're jumping around a time until
they stop jumping around in time and she
faces him Luke Skywalker Vader style
they will not be able to stop him
she can do as much Jedi training as she
wants they can jump around in time all
they want but until she puts dagger to
chest he will not go down in my number
one WTF is vandal savage's scorched
earth plan for his like population
control first order of business release
the gas don't you just wonder what
vandal savage's plant like in the
context of the TV show not the comic
book version of Vandal Savage what his
plan is once he does conquer the earth
he's all about survival of the fittest
but is he just intending for the
strongest metahumans to live on how is
it gonna work like in his mind what does
his perfect earth look like right now
I'm thinking of this crazy Charles
Manson Eyes Wide Shut scene because he
kind of looks like Charles Manson and
he's just as crazy as he is
but they're that whole cult Eyes Wide
Shut orgy vibe going on we're just a
little bit freaky a little bit
uncomfortable but let me know if you
guys picked up on the idea of them not
being able to change the future no
matter what they do like they keep
jumping around timeline still totally
effed doesn't it feel like they're gonna
keep spinning their wheels - Hawkgirl
picks that dagger up and stabs Vandal
Savage in the heart with it you know on
top of that when are we gonna see
Hawkman reincarnated they haven't really
explained how that works on the TV show
they're jumping around in time so at
some point they will have to run into a
future version
of Hawkman but you can kind of see from
a distance that none of the story is
really about Hawkman this is really
about developing hawkgirl's character
it's all about her journey her rise to
the level where she's able to kill
Vandal Savage so I'm wondering if
they're gonna leave Hawkman dead through
season two or if he'll come back the
problem with the show is this is just so
many characters so if you want to bring
new characters on you have to get rid of
the old characters which is also an
interesting thing about arrow this
season now no spoilers for arrow just in
case you haven't watched it I'll do a
bonus video for that because they might
be bringing on a new character in season
5 it remains to be seen but I have a
whole bunch of Flash stuff to talk about
so be sure to subscribe to get that
video flash stuff we'll post sometime
tomorrow tomorrow morning got some black
siren got some Power Girl stuff to talk
about so just get hype for earth-1 Power
Girl and actually I almost forgot next
week's legends of tomorrow is going to
be the Jonah Hex episode so be sure to
watch that next Thursday why you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for my Game of Thrones
episode 1 teaser video and you can click
here for my arrow WTF video from this
week for the you know big character that
died thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight